let's go next to uh we're gonna go to
sam from houston sam from houston is
joining us
uh sam i would say what's your name and
where are you calling from but i already
have that information
and you're gonna have to unmute yourself
sam if you want to chat which which we
want we want you to unmute
um but you do have to unmute yourself
sam from houston you've gotta unmute you
are muted there you go sam
hey david how are you doing good how are
you i'm doing
i feel like i ptsd after that debate
right
uh so i guess i wanted to get your take
on um
the biggest i way that the left will
look at the debate for biden
yesterday and mostly from the standpoint
i guess of
whoever is still undecided at this point
how do you view
their reaction their
viewpoint so you're saying specifically
left-wing undecideds people who are
politically left but they're not sure
about voting biden yet
right right i i mean listen this is so
speculative and we really have to wait
for the polling
but my instinct is that there will be
some on the left and they're very loud
on twitter and on reddit there will be
some on the left who will say
biden stumbled and bumbled and we can't
have this guy
in office but then they're gonna vote
the guy in
who talked about biden's son's cocaine
problem
and said he needs that the proud boys to
stand
by for after the election like that's
how you that's who you're going to go
with so
i think we shouldn't uh be be
tricked into thinking that a lot of the
left is reacting to biden by saying wow
now i'm voting trump because of that
debate
i think that for the left remember most
undecideds aren't left-wing
undecideds tend to be center and
center-right who don't pay too much
attention but
for left-wing undecideds i think biden
was stable and trump was a petulant
child and it probably helps biden with
the left-wing undecided
there's very few of them though
yeah i i think that that's the best way
to look at last night
because of the fact that it was just
screaming and is there anything that you
would advise the next
moderator for the next debate because
chris the modern
moderator needs to be able to control
the microphones of the candidates both
candidates would have to agree to it and
it's not going to happen
so what i think the next best thing can
be
is the moderate this could make the
debate last twice as long but the
moderator should enforce
that if trump interrupts biden biden's
time
stops and it gets taken away from trump
so for example
and it's very hard to do if biden's
supposed to get two minutes and trump
talks for 30 of it
biden gets another 30 and that 30 counts
against
trump's next time slot they're not going
to allow it they're not going to do it
it's logistically difficult but what
else can you do oh
i would i would love that i think that
that would be the best thing to be able
to cut
one of the uh both of their mics off
because it was bad but but
they both need to agree to it and
they're never going to right
well i'm excited to watch it watch the
next
yeah you're sort of breaking you're sort
of breaking up sam but i i know that
you're saying the kamala uh
pence debate we'll we'll be here for it
i think kamala is going to crush him
yeah thanks so much david appreciate it
all right sam uh sam may have been
exercising or using power tools there so
we're gonna
let him let him get back to it uh let's
go back
to um oh here
i think this is a call from uh i think
this is a call from
israel let's go to peleg
from ashkelon peleg what's going on uh
and remember you have to unmute yourself
i've brought you in but you've got there
you are hey david how's it going good
how are you
great to talk to you um watch your
livestream yesterday it was awesome
thank you so basically my question is
though
i live in israel and i've been hearing a
lot of talk about biden and his
uh policy towards israel um
so like from one end i can uh i can hear
stuff like oh his bds
is a radical and uh from another uh
side i can hear like uh oh is it good
for us
uh he's friendly to our lobbyists and
stuff like that so
i guess my question is um what's your
opinion about biden's policy towards
israel and uh
um yeah your general opinion on it well
it's not about my opinion it's what is
biden said so first you said you heard
that
some people said biden's for bds has
bayed never studies for bds
i could not find that yeah he hasn't
said it so biden's not for bds
with with regard to the relationship
biden would be completely
unremarkable in his relationship to
israel it would be very similar to
barack obama
i mean certainly if benjamin netanyahu
is not a factor the relationship will be
improved and you might get a credible
opportunity for
for serious uh peace discussions but
there is going to be nothing remarkable
at all about it's sort of like trump
says biden will end the second amendment
now biden will try to get
some sensible reforms passed maybe
universal background checks and a few
other things
it will be very similar to what barack
obama tried to do trump says biden's
going to end the suburbs and you know
kind of this racial uh
dog whistling no he's not and there are
some on the right saying biden will be
terrible for israel or for american jews
or whatever
no he won't he will be completely
unremarkable in in
every way with his with regard to israel
israeli policy
great that's exactly what i think too
and i tried to explain that to people
great peleg what's going on now in
israel in terms of
masks so a lot of people i follow who
live in israel
they're out in cafes they're at gyms not
wearing masks what's the deal yeah that
is a problem and we've had like a lot of
talk about it
and also like uh now right now there are
a lot of pro protests against uh
benjamin netanyahu yeah
every like i think saturday i might be
wrong about it
uh so a lot of people don't wear master
and a lot of criticism about that
um from what i know right now we are on
a shutdown
it's gonna end like you know about five
days so uh
uh right now it seems to be uh steady
and
in terms of masks people generally
respect it and
yeah okay because i don't see anybody
wearing masks but they respect when it
when you're supposed to you're saying
people are wearing a mask
when i usually go out i see about
70 percent of people wear masks but
might be my memory that's not bad that's
not bad okay all right
like i'm gonna let you go sounds like
you're juggling a lot over there but i
appreciate
hearing from you one of our sponsors
today
is vincero watches and they're giving
you up to 30 percent
off everything in their store when you
go to davidpakman.com
slash watch if you're looking for an
awesome way to update your look
the perfect way to do it is with an
elegant high quality
wrist watch when there's a company like
vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on
a watch vincero is an american company
that's made it possible to own
an excellent watch without breaking the
bank all of their watches
are masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com slash
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video